fair warning
this is gonna be weirder than usual
can't be helped
you called me
so here i am
[Music]
i know i shut you out sometimes
i'm always glad to hear from you
it's just that
i get my hopes up
so many times it's led to nothing
i found nothing
it's like
we live in a room
and there's a poster on the wall
we stare at it and we think that's the
whole world
the room
and the poster
the picture's something nice
a landscape a famous person
like in that movie
what is it called
the prison movie
the room's a cell and the picture it's
different for each of us it can be
beautiful
or terrible but we're all transfixed
but it's all a lie
something to distract us from the truth
they're lying to us
we're lying to ourselves
the rooms not the world the world
is much bigger and much stranger
there's a hole hidden behind that poster
that leads to the real world
we all feel safe in that room
but sometimes
sometimes something crawls out from
behind the poster
the ones that see it happen
freak out
and try to forget what they saw
i'm here
why did you bring me here
hello
anyone here
federal bureau of control
all these years i've been looking for
them and they were hiding in plain sight
hello
hey excuse me
there you are you are here about the job
janitor's assistant
you need to go to the interview
go that way to the elevator
thanks
elevator that way
got it
very good
janitor quite okay you'll work for me
you can say i sent you
if they don't hire you either
you are no hell of it
there'll be work for the axe
take them behind the sound
i've done enough night shift lunar jobs
to know it makes us come off weird
auntie the janitor is a friendly face in
my book
this seal
i saw it a long time ago
i keep seeing it in my dreams
the cell
and the poster
i was 11 years old the first time i saw
behind the poster they told me i
imagined it
i've been trying to pull it down ever
since
will you help
[Music]
[Applause]
did i lose you there for a moment
you know what's on my mind
my baby brother dylan
17 years since the men of this bureau
took him
uh
[__]
[__] [__] [__]
you want me to pick it up the murder
weapon really
[Music]
and there goes the poster
objects of power
can cause or be results of awes altered
world events intrusions upon the
perceived reality now
the service weapon is of course a prime
example of an oop a very
powerful one
ingrained in the bureau's dna a key
component in our prime candidate program
come out of that russian roulette a
winner and you
you're it
oh look at this place
the same gun
[Music]
okay
now i have a gun
so
oh
how are you coming up
[Music]
something's coming
this threat
an attack
duty as director
keep the bureau safe
did you hear that
it's the dead man
right after the pyramid spoke to me and
it was just noise and i understood every
word
and this gun's alive
you know what
i'm happy
happy to be here
things have quieted down outside
is it safe to go
you can't let this happen
you stopped it
you
oh thank you
that was
horror
[__]
the hotline
secure line of communications
[Music]
okay
uh
reminder
[Music]
if there are
a hissing sound that tried to invade me
earlier the hiss
burrowing into everything in this place
is the hiss your enemy
all right it's our enemy
that battle's contagious it burrows in
like an infuriating melody that makes
you hum it over and over
[Music]
so
uh
[Applause]
the hissing sound that tried to invade
me earlier
the hiss
burrowing into everything in this place
is the hiss your enemy
all right it's our enemy
that battle's contagious it burrows in
like
over and over
[Applause]
must cleanse control points
cleanse the control point what does that
mean help me fix it
holy [__]
you did it
we did it
hello
can you hear me
are you with us
we're the bureau
are you still sane
please talk to me
we saw you deal with the
compromised agents
[Music]
i can't tell you how happy i am to talk
to somebody sane
the feeling's mutual
i'm pope emily pope and dr darling's
assistant
my turn
should i lie
jesse faden i'm just visiting
i should have lied
oh [__]
you're the new director
hold on we're coming out
director
faden
call me jesse
okay jesse
i'm emily
look somehow this hostile force this
hiss
that works
somehow the hiss managed to infiltrate
the building without any warning and
just like that my name for it is
official the hiss
like the sound of poison gas leaking in
we're in full lockdown it seems to have
spread everywhere and to everyone not
protected by an hra and
extraordinarily
you
you are the director and that makes you
special by definition
trench is no longer the director
obviously
uh i'm sorry i'm talking too much this
whole situation is just
a
lot
trench is dead
shot
ah
i found his body
and the gun
do i tell her look like a suicide
the service weapon also
and this can sound crazy
but he keeps appearing to me
saying things
it's hard to make out but he told me to
cleanse the control point
push the hiss out
the whole room shifted around
you did that
and you entered the building when it was
already in the lockdown before you
became the new director
how
i'm not ready to tell her about you yet
a janitor let me in
i love it this is [__] unbelievable
it's
i can't even
look jesse
i have a million questions and
you probably have a million more
like do you know my brother dylan
not yet
but there's something i need to ask you
to do first
if you can cleanse a control point
then you can maybe cure those infected
or
possessed by the hiss
because if that's possible
our options are
very different
emily pope
i don't know her but i like her already
she's the opposite of the faceless
agency i've blamed for what happened to
me for so
long but i can't trust her yet
or rather the bureau she's a part of
yes
i can try
i'm speaking for you of course
we can try it together
okay
you with me
we did it before
push the hiss out
oh
after this
[Music]
you can't stop
oh
[Music]
it didn't work the hiss has burrowed too
deep
ripping it out rips them apart
i can't cleanse them
i saw
it was worth a shot thank you director
jesse
i'm gonna tell her why i'm here
i'll risk it
listen
the bureau was involved in an
incident in my hometown ordinary
17 years ago
the bureau came in and covered the whole
thing up
i've been looking for this place for a
long time
that's enough
maybe that's too much already
i can't tell her about dylan and the
rest yet
i've seen mentions of an altered world
event case dealing with ordinary
you were at ground zero as a child
it was one of the big ones and before my
time
and very classified
i can try to dig out some old files for
you
my boss casper darling would know but
he's missing
i think he knew this was coming or
suspected
he came up with the hras the hedron
resonance amplifiers
i think they're what saved us
a few of us
and director trench would know
trench the
ghost or
whatever he is
he mentioned something called the
hotline
said i should find it
it's another object of power like the
gun an old bakelite telephone a direct
line of communication between the
director and the board
maybe he can talk to you more clearly
through that
trench has years and years of experience
he might know how to destroy the hiss
where is the hotline
it's kept in the communications
department through the mail room it's
part of this sector so we can access it
even with the lockdown in place
we'll get the door open for you
okay
that's my next stop
that's tamazi's department he's the head
of communications
i don't think he had an h.r.a he kind of
made a point about not wearing one
earlier
keep an eye out
they call me the director
but that's not me
i'm not a director type
not a leader
why am i here
i think you already know
yes i came for my brother but there are
other reasons too
i said i was looking for answers but i
might never understand them
i'm not looking for proof this is
already it more than enough
no matter what they told me all those
years i know
it's real now
i didn't imagine this
i want to be a part of this world
what scares me shitless is that i
finally found it
only to see the hiss
destroy it all
[Music]
i know this is all new to you so don't
hesitate to ask me anything you want to
know there are no stupid questions
the door to the comms department is just
outside the boardroom back in the lobby
they should have gotten it open right
now
there it is again a welcome message
[Music]
so
just look at it
eight inches wide and capable of storing
a whopping 80 kilobytes
stolen by our friends at the cia the
disc held the launch codes to soviet
nukes
this is not the disc of course but
one exactly like it a perfect fusion of
concepts vibrating in the cold war era
collective unconscious
a receptacle
it is a receptacle for dangerous
energies to hone in on and they did
we don't have the details but when
things started flying around the disk it
was transferred to us
it's an object of power
oh oop
oops
oh and it can launch things
telekinetically through the air to date
we we've launched
maybe
three dozen pencils
and once
we even launched a cup
[Music]
communications
are on the right track
an object of power
we need to cleanse it
um
[Music]
it's harder to hear you when i'm here
it's like
the channel's been changed
the board's in charge here they're
pyramids in bureau seal
are they really the ones pulling the
strings
i'm not their director
i'm no one's director
oh
uh
ugh
[Music]
foreign
um
there you are
you were gone
cut off
i got it
just like you wanted right this will
help me fight the hiss
[Music]
two
oh
[Music]
so
happiness
right
emily said that the hotline can be
reached through the mail
this must open the door
more
oh
great
[Music]
uh
oh
whoa
so
i have a feeling he'll be back
let's stay focused
the hotline should be past the mailroom
um
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
this
all right take this down the situation
in cuba has been evaluated by the
relevant authorities the mysterious
illness affecting the staff at the u.s
embassy in havana was caused by sonic
weaponry in the hands of a foreign power
numerous personnel have damage to the
inner ear but most are expected to make
a full recovery of course the event also
damaged their cellular walls but again
[Music]
head of calms god no local doctors
examine them first the
are you still recording this
[Music]
the hotline can't be far now
the ocean view hotel and casino
dream logic
the light switch court
have we been here before
no
i've stayed a lot of roadside motels
across the country on the road
on the run under the radar
this feels like
all of them like
something recognized from a dream
[Music]
the key has a black pyramid on it
foreign
[Music]
uh
it is a
phone it's an object of power
it doesn't connect to any typical
network a direct line to the astral
plane and the board
and my hypothesis is
under the right conditions to other
planes of existence as well
[Music]
a director needs a team
my management team these people know the
secrets of the bureau as well as i do
some even better
darling tomasi salvador marshall
marshall especially my head of
operations
she sees right through me
she knows i don't like relying on people
the only person you should fail is
yourself
but things change when you become
director
i have it the hotline
i can reach trench well listen to him
he feels more like an echo
an echo with important info
i need to get back to emily
you